good morning everyone thank you for
joining this session I hope that there
is no one standing because we do have a
she says okay no one's doing cool so do
you remember 10 years ago 2007 when
people didn't really think that smart
phones would really become something
do you remember 2008 only top executives
and a few nerds starting buying the
smart phones and actually using them and
do you remember how straight after this
trend exploded upwards and finally do
you remember how many of you maybe
thought oh I wish I had spotted that
trend a bit earlier I wish I had put
more resources into it before I'm not
asking for show of hands but I'm sure it
happened in some companies this change
is happening again right now towards
conversational computing and smart
assistance you may have heard this
morning from Rishi that products of the
future and trying to quote precisely
products of the future should be
conversational and assistive this is
what today's is today is about this
journey is happening right now and we're
just at the beginning of this typical
new product adoption curve we've spotted
the trend we try to apply it to us at
Google and this is one last year we've
announced the Google assistant it's a
natural conversation between you and
Google the assistant is there to help
you throughout your day and it's there
to help you and to help users across one
across more than 100 million devices
it's down your phone it's on Android
it's on iOS it's down on your watch in
your headset you can have the the pixel
birth but you can also have the latest
balls headsets for instance the
assistant is there it can be on your
speakers we have Google home Google home
mini we have more speakers that are
integrated from Sonos Sony
jlb and so
it can be also on your laptop if you get
a pixel book it can be on your TV if you
have an Android TV and I'm sure
forgetting a few I think I covered them
most of them and there are more surfaces
coming there may be a huge hint on this
light but I'm not gonna spoil it just
now there are just more and more
surfaces coming so the audience is
pretty big and the beauty of the
assistant is that it blends the latest
advances in terms of machine learning
you've heard so far this morning a lot
about machine learning it has also
artificial intelligence and natural
language processing so it creates this
very advanced conversation that is
assistive and when I say conversation I
don't mean just voice because with the
assistant you can talk but you can also
type you can tap or you can even use
your camera meaning you're in a session
let's say during your conference
approaching the lunchtime you want to
organize your lunch plans maybe you
don't want to speak it to your device
maybe you want to use a keyboard instead
you can do that or even within the same
conversation you may start with your
voice asking for a nice restaurant then
being willing to look at a menu and tap
a few options on your screen and then
use a keyboard to actually confirm your
order so all of this can happen within
the same conversation and with the
camera if you are in a super busy
situation on the street you don't want
to use a keyboard you don't want to try
to shout at your device on the busy
street you can just use your camera
point out something and get the
assistant starting from there with the
relevant information this is the
beginning of your conversation directly
from your environment extremely powerful
the assistant is really there to help
you get things done from your daily
things like building up your shopping
list to enjoying your media your
favorite media at home you can start
your music I know I use it to start head
shoulders knees and toes to play with my
little one at home I don't have to take
my phone I don't have to do anything I
can just talk to my Google Holman and it
starts so you can start your movie as
well you can also dim your lights to
enjoy that movie you can do all of that
all of your comfy comforting zone at
home you can set up thanks to your
assistant same in the morning you're in
a rush you're brushing your teeth in the
bathroom you can listen to your news
using the assistant there are already
many features that are available that
can really help you get things done
throughout your day and with actions in
Google there is going to be much more so
what you want to do as a company first
of all the assistant comes with all of
the Google properties so you want to
make sure that you're happy with your
presence within the existing Google
ecosystem are you happy with the way you
show up on search the way you show up on
maps with your content on YouTube
because all of that that's the beauty of
the assistant can be leveraged to your
users directly we're going into machine
learning so it's going to be leveraged
but it needs to be right so make sure
you you invest some time on that same
with your data if you are say a news
publisher you want to leverage your
archive corpus you may want to throw a
few markups at it before it's leveraged
by the assistant but the all of this
thinking you need to keep embedding in
your roadmap to make sure that you can
leverage the full power of the
assistance the second layer where you
can take action and this is why we're
here today is actions in Google it's the
developer platform that allows you to
build stuff for the assistant from the
smartphone integration if you happen to
produce your own smart bulbs to creating
conversational apps and we're super
proud because we launched actions in
Google last year only in English only in
the US as we tend to do because that's
where our engineers are and we need to
get started somewhere but already over
the past months we've added first of all
additional variations to just English
now you can build specifically in
British English Australian English
Canadian English and also in additional
languages Japanese Korean and my two
favorite in French and in German if
you're talking about a voice product
this is tremendous accomplishment but it
was not enough for engineers so they
kept adding stuff to what you can do
with actions in Google and they added a
few visual elements as well so now you
can embed an image carousel to make sure
that your user can swipe through the
options that are available you can also
use a few suggestion ships so that if
your user is using your assistant app on
a phone he can be guided throughout the
conversation flow you can give that
input to the conversation and last but
not least let's see we've added
transactional capabilities meaning that
users in the US for now but coming soon
to the UK and to further countries users
can now order goods and services
just imagine the potential of that this
is pretty big and what I'm trying to say
here is that now is really the right
time to start building an app for the
assistant you have a massive audience
more than 100 million devices you have a
platform that is not crowded yet and for
some services we barely have any app yet
or we don't even have anyone yet so you
have a massive opportunity there to be
the first and you have the opportunity
to be the first or even second which
globally is still pretty good you also
have thanks to the assistant to the
conversation product you have the
opportunity to have this one-on-one
conversation with your users if you
wanted to call them one by one you
couldn't do it even so precisely this is
the brand new technology where you can
address them one by one separately they
are all signed in
so just make sure you leverage that and
in terms of timing the last thing you
want to do is to wait for additional
features to be available in your country
you don't want to wait for say
transactions to be available in Germany
before you start looking at your 2018
roadmap and say okay which developer can
we free up 20% to start looking at this
what you want to do is to build a team
right now have a few people give them
the time to learn about smart assistants
not just the Google assistant all of
them they need to learn they need to
train themselves they need to launch
they need to iterate and you want to be
ready so that every time a new feature
new capability comes in you're already
there and you only have two entrance but
this is very important start building
your team right now and here are a few
insights briefly to get you started
conversation is more than information
retrieval this is very important
everybody is super curious I'm sure
about the address of your business your
opening times but for a smart assistant
can be a bit boring you may want to do
more than that you want to try to be
entertaining read fits and customize in
your information you also want to be
assistive everywhere where you use a
song we said you have 100 million
devices you want to make sure that you
build an experience that fits for every
device so that the user doesn't see you
as a nice update your news on their
Google home but as the one app they want
to use for this service throughout their
services on the watch on the phone on
the go any situation and last but not
least when you start building your app
the first thing you have to do before
you even build is to think thoroughly
about your use case you want to take one
or two days a very conscious mindset
from the time you wake up in the morning
to the time you go to bed and identify
all of these tiny
where you think I wish technology could
make that easier for me if you find one
that fits well with your brand you have
your use case and this is where you
should start building so with no further
ado I think it's better that I stop
saying you should you shouldn't but that
you here for someone who has gone
through this process and please welcome
on stage plain from the kiss hi that's
my face I'm Benjamin stolid in the head
of audio at blinker blinker is an app
that is helping people learn by taking
the core ideas of nonfiction books and
giving them to you in a way you can
either read or listen to okay so why
were we so eager to build an app for the
Google assistant quick show of hands
this is kind of dumb but it's easy how
many people listen to audio content in
the last week podcasts interviews yeah
everybody so why were we so excited to
build something for the Google
assistance because audio is magic you
guys all said you listen to audio but
not just that you guys were probably
doing something while listening to audio
and audio is magic because it's the only
thing that you can fully focus on a
fully focusing on something else how
else can you describe or explain that
feeling when you put on your favorite
episode of this American life and then
it's over and you come to and all of a
sudden dinner's ready
Audio is magic and a blink is we're
trying to figure out how to give people
these kind of aha enlightening moments
in ways that fit their lifestyles the
modern knowledge worker it needs to
learn everywhere so this is the bling
kissed minute originally conceived we
used it to give people more content a
cool one minutes worth of information a
cool fact cool story joke takeaway from
a great book in a way where they where
they already were we met them where they
were in their inboxes it was a daily
email audio can work in the same way if
you meet people where they're already
listening go to where people are already
listening it's a seem simple but it's
really awesome because if we've as we've
already learned the Google assistant is
going to be available on a hundred
million plus connected devices and
that's even more important considering
what we know about how people are
listening you guys all raise your hands
this none of this is surprising anymore
let's take podcast as a stand-in for
audio content that people like to learn
from can be interviews can be courses it
can be audio books we know that people
are listening a lot and it's growing and
we know that people are listening
everywhere they're listening at the gym
they listen at work they listen in the
car they listen on the bike and with a
hundred million plus connected devices
like it's a no-brainer so that's why we
were so excited how did we do it
few simple steps quick number one find a
developer see you out there probably
number two lockdown persona more on that
in a second number three start on the
conversations and use the tools that
Google gives you three and four real
quick conversations is becoming like a
buzzword now in the term we heard logons
talk about conversations as more than
information retrieval go through the
Google documentation on conversations
it's really helpful because as you all
know from first dates and bad networking
events starting a conversation is hard
sometimes and that's because like our
testers found out when we put them in a
room with Google home with the blinkers
minute and Google assistant in the home
the question is sometimes what do I say
and that's the whole thing it's not easy
to start a conversation especially with
something new so you could see that as a
challenge or you could see it as
something kind of fun we have a new
technology and we get to play with it
and figure out how people are going to
use it because the technical
implementation is not really the
challenge there's a lot of smart people
here Google has made it so easy to make
the stuff even I understand how to do it
and it's not the challenge of actually
building the tech the challenge is going
to be how people use it what do I say
what am I talking to what is it actually
gonna do once I say something and then
we
so that can go down a kind of scary
mind-bending path but we try to keep it
simple instead of thinking about what am
I talking to we took Google's advice and
tried to think about Who am I talking to
I mean bling kiss is a company that it's
trying to help people learn we read
books like it's a it's awesome and our
products have to reflect that because
it's what we know so if we're trying to
help people learn the minute the
assistant the minute on Google assistant
just have a persona that makes sense
she's friendly she's attentive she's
funny but she's also smart she's got it
under control she wants to help you
learn something she's gonna be wherever
you want to learn something right there
give you a quick minute to help you out
and that's just a piece of advice
someone I want to keep in mind
lavon's also also hinged on it we don't
know necessarily how people are gonna
use these technologies they're they're
out there for us to build we're gonna
build on them but if we don't know what
habits what behaviors they're gonna lead
to and stick to what you know stick to
your brand stick to your use cases
so we're queue up the video there's a
one minute video file a minute for
Google assistant or work okay google
talk to blink Asst minute all right
here's the Linkous minute hey sleepyhead
we're adding some draw de vivre to your
morning's in this blankest minute called
you snooze you lose
you can sooth your email addiction in
this Linkous minute called stop looking
at your emails now you probably know
that your liver is essentially your
body's sewage plant in this minute we
take a look at a surprisingly simple way
to shave a few inches off your waist
how much do you concentrate on your food
when you eat you probably tend to gulp
down your food while reading messaging
or gawking at videos
study after study has shown that in
order to perform at our best we need a
good night's sleep listen to this
blankest minute called Thomas Edison the
man who hated sleep
the blink is minute helping you fit new
knowledge into your daily routines big
ideas from nonfiction books brought to
life okay its core it again what
suddenly the video is trying to show
meeting people where they already are
giving them audio with everybody are you
so soon to finish what I want to say
like we're all in here because we want
to see where this is going
this was super helpful for me if you
don't know follow the advice of wizard
men David Allen on the simplified
podcast look it up if you don't know it
and just get moving and course correct
we got moving I hope you guys do too
that's it for me I'll give it back to
the ones to finish this off
Thank You Ben thank you for sharing your
your learnings your best practices
very briefly we've just launched a
community program this is for developers
there are some perks first of all if
your app is reviewed and approved you
can get $200 per month in cloud credits
this should cover more than what you
need to run your app so it's an iceberg
you also get a very fancy t-shirt so
don't miss out on that one
and very importantly as well if you have
high usage and engaging up a few
international it internationalize your
app and you are gonna be able to win
Google home and additional goodies so it
sounds a bit trivial but hopefully it's
a true motivation there is obviously
like a winner dashboard so it should be
a nice motivation for the developers and
here are the resources the very fancy QR
code here we made it happen there is
even a small teddy bear in the middle
and she can spot that that's going to
lead you to the instructions to try out
the assistant depending on your device
now share more on the product developer
site this is what you want to take a
picture of this are the links that are
going to bring you to the relevant
documentation developers.google.com
slash actions you have everything from
the design to the console to the review
process and the policy process we also
have a developer community there is a G+
community there is massive community on
Stack Overflow
and we have a mailing list so if you
want to know the latest what's happening
what's launching what's enhanced to make
sure that you sign up for that
newsletter it's a global newsletter so
you're going to hear from the latest
from in the US but also for your region
and your country thank you very much
you